🎶
Hello, everyone, and welcome to the table.
It is so good to see everybody here tonight.
We're so glad to have you with us,
and that includes those of you joining us here online.
Before we begin, I do have just a couple of announcements.
First of all, as our relationship event coming up,
do you want to improve your relationship with a significant other?
Regardless of your relationship status,
whether you are married or just dating,
we hope you join us for a workshop
focused on enhancing communication skills
and navigating personality dynamics.
Our hope is that through self-discovery and practical tools,
you can learn how to build a stronger partnership.
You can RSVP by scanning the code on the screen,
or the code that will be on the screen momentarily,
and free child care will be available for those who attend.
Secondly is Easter service coming up.
Now, Jesus may have risen early on Easter Sunday,
but you don't have to.
That is because our Easter service is going to be held
on Saturday evening, April 19th, at 5 p.m.
So same time, same place, just a day early.
And we hope you join us, not only for our service,
but for the community meal that we'll be having
at the Family Life Center afterwards.
If you have any questions, you can get with me, with Brett,
or with any of the Elder Team members,
and we'll get you taken care of.
Now, before we begin service,
Chloe Kaiser is going to start us off with a call to prayer.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry, and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence, stillness,
and simplicity, sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and adoration,
a place to behold Christ, revelation of God,
heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to find you,
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
♪♪♪
♪♪
All right.
Forgive us while we transition here for just a moment.
But, as I'm sure you've already either heard when you arrived
or if you were late into the building,
we have some new faces on the stage tonight,
or some different faces, I should say,
because it's Youth Sunday.
Yay! Yes! Right? That's awesome.
And I'm so excited.
I'm so proud of them.
I just, there are a few things that I look forward to more
than seeing these students who oftentimes you guys don't get to see
because they're back serving in our kids' ministry area every week,
in classrooms, or, you know, like they're in here on a rotation
because they're back there serving,
or after the service they're back in the youth room.
And to see them be part of this community,
not just as someone who is served, but someone who is serving,
and using their gifts, and knowing that what they have
is good enough to make a difference and to bless people.
And I am one of those kids who had so many grown-ups in their lives
saying, you have something to offer.
And I was never, ever, ever even allowed to be on the back row.
I mean, not because it was like this rule.
It was just from the beginning I was invited into the front lines
of whatever was happening.
And I'm so thankful that I was raised in a community like that.
It literally changed my life.
I mean, majorly.
So as soon as we were doing anything related to church planting,
the first thing I was looking for was the students
because I was one of those kids.
That's where it started for me,
was as a little 7th grade girl with my crazy youth pastor
coming up to me and being like,
hey, you want to start leading worship every Wednesday night at our, you know,
and I didn't know what I was doing.
And it turned into a lifelong, just fulfilling invitation into ministry.
So I hope that happens for them.
And I'm just proud of them for saying yes.
So the three people you see in front of you tonight
have agreed to be part of our message portion of the service.
And Hank Humble is going to be kind of our point guy.
And, yes.
Hank is skilled and talented in a thousand ways.
A thousand ways, y'all.
He's so dang gifted.
It's unreal.
And I'm just really excited that you get to hear from him tonight.
And Maylynn is next to him.
And Maylynn, yes.
Give Maylynn a hand.
Maylynn is a junior at Sac State High School.
And this is like the most upfront thing that Maylynn maybe has ever done
in their whole entire life.
So I'm like beaming with pride already,
and nothing's even come out of your mouth yet.
Just them sitting here right now is like, yes, victory!
No one forced you into it, though, right?
Yeah.
This is like a major step of courage.
And then this is Chloe Kaiser next to me.
And you guys already got to hear a little bit from her.
But hopefully you'll get to know them a little bit better.
And we're going to just be talking and sharing some of the things
that we've been focusing on in youth since the beginning of the year in January.
And I'm going to kick it over to you guys.
Hank, are you good on that mic?
I think so.
Test, test.
Okay.
I'll put this one down then.
All right.
Good evening, everybody.
How's it going?
Let's see.
Everybody make the turnout.
So my name is Hank.
I am 17 years old.
My pronouns are he, him.
And tonight we're going to be talking about just stuff we've been going over in youth.
And we have a few questions too.
So I'll take it to you all.
What is your name and your pronouns?
Hello.
I'm Maylynn.
And my pronouns, I go by Annie.
I'm Chloe, and I go by she, her.
Awesome.
All right.
So we are part of the youth.
We are a pretty fun bunch.
Next slide, please.
Yeah.
So you can see we've got some pictures up.
We hang out, have snacks, play games.
It's usually about like 6.15, 6.30 to 8.
And if we schedule well enough, sometimes we even do some Bible study at the end of our talk.
But, yeah, it's a really fun time to just kind of reflect.
It's a really safe space for me especially.
I've felt like I've been able to vent and just share the things that have been heavy on my mind.
It's one of my favorite times of the week.
So next slide, please.
The themes we've been going over recently are kind of awareness, just being more connected to those around you,
personal ownership and owning up to your own shortcomings, realizing that we're all flawed in some way,
and just being more understanding, just being a cool, chill guy, you know, being a well-rounded individual.
Next slide, please.
With that, we've been also going over the Enneagram a lot lately.
Some people are kind of like, oh, that's like the astrology, whatever, pseudoscience.
Well, but it's a lot more like a personal compass.
It's a really useful tool for being better aided to learn more about those around you,
understanding yourself, and just, yeah, being a good person.
Not a good person, but, you know.
With that in mind, it's kind of just the idea of primary strengths and flaws within ourselves,
and we all have our own kind of like centric driving force.
They break it up into three.
It's the two, three, and four are the heart center.
The body center is eight, nine, and one, and the mind is five, six, and seven.
I usually kind of lead towards heart, but really we all have a little bit of each type within us,
but one has kind of pushed to the top over time.
And not everybody has a type.
Usually children don't really have types.
It kind of is something that develops more once you've matured a little bit.
I personally am an Enneagram type four.
It's kind of the angsty one.
I'm kind of in my motions right now.
They say a lot about it being like trying to understand a sense of self,
but it's also kind of feels like there's something missing a lot of the time,
or like people don't try to connect more with people, but maybe they don't quite get it.
So like at their best, you can see on the left side, we're authentic people.
We wear our colors, but in our worst, we're hopeless.
It's just terrible.
So with that in mind, I'll take it over to our panel.
My question is what is your Enneagram type, and what does it mean to you?
Okay, so I am a type nine with a wing one.
Type nine is a peacemaker, meaning I strive for harmony and peace,
not only in my environment, but with myself.
Our fears are afraid of disconnection.
So like that, yeah, definitely.
We are known as doormats in the nicest way possible.
We're doormats.
We allow people to do things to us in order to keep the peace,
in order to just keep things the same, which is our weakness.
We are conflict avoidant and too accepting, also very indecisive,
which if you know me, yeah, it will be the downfall of me
because I cannot choose anything for the life of me.
But we are also known to be easygoing, receptive, reassuring, and self-effacing,
meaning we don't claim attention.
And the wing one is called the dreamer.
So they are – it's pretty much just the same.
But when they're doing bad, they don't take risks.
I mean like that's why they're called the dreamer
because they don't take risks in fear of, like, well.
Sorry.
No, you're doing great.
Are you ready to move on?
Well, thank you for sharing, Maylin.
And Chloe, we'd love to hear from you next.
I am a three, which is the achiever.
So I kind of like – I really like to keep my image
and I'm always trying to be achieving something.
I always like to be on the go looking for the next thing.
I find it very hard to fail or to be bad at anything.
And if somebody is better at something than me,
I find that very difficult to get over.
I really long to feel valuable and worthwhile,
like I'm worthy of being somewhere or that people see me as.
Not necessarily like they like to be around me,
but like that girl, she's on it.
She's got everything figured out.
So I have a really big fear of being worthless,
just like people being like, what's she doing over there?
So I see myself as very image conscious
and impatient and competitive and that's kind of my downfalls.
Once I get something figured out, I'm kind of like,
well, why can't you figure this out too?
I don't want to wait for you to catch up to me.
So sometimes it's hard for me to decide what's more important,
like God's opinions, like over my grain,
like if I get a worse grade on a friend than something
or even if I do better but I don't get the perfect score,
I'm like, well, it's easy for me to feel proud of others,
but I'm just like, well, those are five or ten points that you missed,
so you're still a failure.
So it's definitely been having to have some come to Jesus moments
of being like, your worth does not come from how you perform,
it comes from God.
So, yeah.
Thank you, Chloe.
That was wonderful.
So one of the other key themes we've been kind of discussing
and just one of the key values at the church as a whole
is the idea of eclecticism, the being eclectic.
The Webster Dictionary over here describes it as
deriving ideas, styles, or tastes from a broad and diverse range of sources.
So, yeah, eclectic mix of courses.
I included this in the slide to kind of give us a chance to share
just some fun little things we like talking about,
but my question for everybody is,
what are some things in life that you've found God in
or that have given you peace and faith?
So I'll share first.
Some things that have been really driving for me recently
are I've found some new friends within my school.
As a 4, it's been hard for me to find good friends,
but church has been a good home for me,
but also needing to kind of out in the rest of the world.
I've recently found a good group of friends who are my main supporters.
They've been my main crew,
and it's been really nice to be able to just vent
and hang out and have a good time.
I've also developed a little bit of a green thumb myself lately.
It's been...
I've kind of seen it in a perspective of...
I've found faith in it,
from feeling it like it's taking God's gifts and sources from the earth
and being able to cultivate it.
It just kind of makes my heart feel good.
Seeing the plants grow, I'm like,
I'm doing it, but it's God doing it.
Like, what is...
And I've also had this little Mr. Rogers calendar
that stays up above my desk on this little bookshelf,
but it always has a little quote of wisdom,
inspiration in the mornings,
and they're really nice.
And this blue one up here kind of relates to what we've been talking about,
of there's the good guy and the bad guy in all of us,
and knowing that doesn't ever need to overwhelm us.
Or when we value childhood and the many things children can do,
we're letting them know that we don't expect them to be more grown-ups
than they're already ready to be.
We like them just the way they are.
Yeah.
So with that in mind, the question for each of you is,
what are some things in life that you've found God in,
or given you peace and faith?
So one of the things I find God in is...
Oh, my name's spelled wrong.
It's okay. It's okay.
Is art.
My life is very chaotic,
especially with my family,
and being a junior halfway through the school year
where you're getting ready to look for colleges and everything,
it's just, like, chaotic.
So art gives me a chance to just, you know, simmer down,
just not really think about things,
and it just allows me to just think about, like,
my relationship with God.
And then kids' ministry, or, well, my nieces,
who are in the middle, those little goofballs.
If you knew me, if you know me,
you know that there's, like, not a day that goes by
where I don't bring them up in some way,
or show you pictures.
I know some of you are probably tired of that.
But I see God in children, especially them.
They are so, like, lively,
and they're so innocent,
and you can just, like, see them
just going about and learning things,
and it's just, like, so amazing.
And then I put Perks of Being a Wallflower,
which is an amazing movie.
Very sad.
Not for many people.
But I resonate with the main character, Charlie,
who is a freshman in high school
and a very awkward, very lonely person.
He went through a lot of traumatic stuff,
like losing his friend and going through sexual abuse.
So I really resonate with him,
because it's just, like, he is messed up in the first part.
And the whole movie is just him
learning to make friends and be healthier.
And he does mess up, like, in the last part of the movie.
He goes through a lot.
And one of the quotes in the movie is,
we accept the love we think we deserve,
which is insanely true on my half,
especially being a peacemaker.
I just let people do things to me,
because I think either I think I deserve it,
or I just, like, don't want to hurt anyone
or don't want to make things worse.
So I just let them do it,
which is not healthy, and I'm trying to get better with that.
I also see many people in my life getting hurt by people
because they think they deserve that.
They don't know that they deserve more than that,
and it hurts a lot.
But at the end of the movie, he ends up finding friends,
which is what I'm getting better with.
I have amazing people in my life,
not just in kids' ministry, I mean kids' ministry,
in youth group, but in school.
I've had friends who I really, like, connect with
who have helped me, like, get a healthier mindset
and, like, just strive for a healthier life.
Thank you for that insight, Malin.
That was wonderful.
And, Chloe, we'd love to hear from you next.
Yes.
So a few things that, a lot of it comes from the shows
I've been watching lately,
which is, the first one is Modern Family,
or more specifically, The Mom, named Claire.
And if you don't know this show,
Claire is, like, the mom of three,
and she has kind of an incompetent husband.
And she's, like, she's very controlling and competitive
and driven, and she gets really impatient.
And I'm, like, as soon as I saw the first episode,
I was, like, I think God is sending me this show
and this woman to grow along with her.
And in this one episode,
this is literally the episode I was thinking about,
Hank got it exactly right.
It was, like, Claire has something done to her
by her husband, and while Claire is, like,
you guys, I'm right, I know I'm right, he did this.
And her husband's, like, no, I didn't.
And I can just see the pain in her face.
She is, like, he did it, I'm right, I know it.
And she goes to crazy lengths to prove that she is right.
And when her kids find out that she is right in the end,
and what she did to prove herself,
they're, like, are you sick, are you okay, are you crazy?
And I was just, like, you know,
maybe sometimes I can step back, too.
And so, as she grows, I just feel
God calling me to grow along with her.
And then that second show there is called Severance.
I've been watching this show with my family recently.
And for those who don't know it, it's kind of complex,
but I'll try to, like, sum it up really quick.
It follows this group of coworkers
whose brains have been, like, surgically divided.
So they don't know, like, they go home,
and they know who they are,
but they don't know what they do at work, and vice versa.
And so there's one character named Helena,
and I resonate deeply with, like,
both parts of her innie and her outie.
So her outie is very composed and driven and confident,
and she's always, like, not trying to lose her patience
or, like, just trying to prove that she's worth where she's at,
which is how I feel a lot of the time when I'm at school,
like, constantly trying to feel like I am enough,
I am worthy to be where I am at,
and just trying to be patient and calm and keeping my mouth shut.
But then outside of school, I feel like her innie,
or who she is, like, at work,
and she's fierce and controlling and independent and impatient
and speaks her mind and unrelenting.
And so at this stage in my life,
I kind of feel God calling me to find, like,
the balance between these Helenas, like, in my own world
and, like, speak my mind,
but also be someone who knows when to back down
and just listen and observe,
but also feel, like, my inside Hellie
and, like, not doubt my worth
and be able to just speak my mind.
And so my last thing is this song called Everything's in Your Hands.
And so throughout this year,
and it being my first year in high school,
I find it very easy to go to school
and have the mindset of you're going to do the best
or you're going to fail.
There's no gray area.
There's no in between.
And so it's really easy to feel like as a three,
my worth is in my performance.
And so whenever I have a stressful test the next day
or I'm about to do, like, a performance for a band or something,
this song is just kind of like,
this song is, like, it's for God.
It's not, at the end of the day,
nothing determines your worth except God
and what you're doing is for God
and all of your power just comes from Him.
So, yeah, this song has just kind of been able to keep me grounded
and steady and guide me forward.
So, yeah.
That's beautiful, Chloe.
It really is a good song.
Thank you for sharing.
So moving along, we have also,
one of the main passages we've been following
is Galatians 6, 1 through 5.
Maggie has actually been a really big promoter of this one.
She's been sharing it a lot with me lately.
And I realized when I was, like, flipping through my Bible I was given here,
when I was looking it up,
I noticed it was highlighted in pink and said,
this one.
Yeah.
So let me share it with you all.
Brothers and sisters, if someone is caught in a sin,
you who live by the Spirit should restore that person gently.
But watch yourselves, or you also may be tempted.
Carry each other's burdens,
and in this way you will fulfill the law of Christ.
If anyone thinks they are something when they are not,
they deceive themselves.
Each one should test their own actions,
and they take pride in themselves alone,
without comparing themselves to someone else,
for each one should carry their own load.
So it's interesting.
There's a lot going on here.
I really like how it kind of brings up topics of the self-dictating
and being more accountable,
but also watching out for your fellow neighbor
and just reaching out a more gracious, kind hand.
So with this in mind,
the question I've kind of posed to kind of wrap us up
is what has this season of life been like for you,
and how have you seen your faith in God play a role in your journey?
So I'll share first.
2025 has been good but hard, hard.
I've been wrapping up my school year,
and time just feels so, so fleeting, so precious.
I have a summer internship option that might come up for me,
but I'm still waiting for them to give me the message back.
So there's been a lot of longing, too,
because it's a whole summer away,
and I have three younger siblings.
These are like the precious moments.
They're losing teeth.
They're learning life lessons.
My little sister just learned how to ride a bike like two days ago.
So it's like, oh, I'm going to come back,
and they're going to be taller than me.
They're still my little siblings,
so I'm still able to get mad at them sometimes,
but they do feel like my kids half the time.
So it's just a lot of heavy stuff,
realizing how quickly things are moving.
So I've been trying to kind of, as much as I can,
kind of center myself again,
kind of slowing it down with things like reading,
more intentional prayer.
I've been trying to avoid prayer in bed,
where I'm just kind of thinking,
and more like before I go to bed,
I usually lay out my yoga mat
and kind of actually get on my knees and pray.
I've noticed it kind of really feels like
more manifesting my relationship with God,
because I've always felt that kind of disconnect.
Like it's just like, I'm just thinking about God,
but when I'm actually like, God,
it feels a lot more real.
So I found some ways to kind of slow it down
and reel in the peace.
So with that in mind, I'd like to ask each of y'all,
what has this season of life been like for you,
and have you seen your faith in God
play a role in your journey?
Okay, so my life could be, like this year,
it could be explained as a roller coaster,
which is ironic, because I'm terrified of roller coasters,
I just don't like heights.
But there's been good days
where I'm just like happy to be here,
I am excited to do things,
and then there's other days where I just struggle
to do the simple tasks, like getting up in the morning,
or like just taking a shower,
which, if you know me, I have to take a shower every day.
Every day, it's, yeah.
But it's just like some days,
I just can't find myself to do it.
But I have to force myself,
because life does not stop even if you're feeling bad.
But recently, I've been taking medication for my anxiety,
which has been helping a lot,
and hopefully in the near future,
I will be finding therapy,
which should be very soon.
And I'm glad I have people I could talk to,
because if it wasn't for that,
I don't know where I would be today.
Sorry, I just got better from a cold.
And it's a lot,
especially like starting to look into colleges,
I am very stressed.
If you did not know that, I am very stressed.
But I have been looking more into finding God.
I was never really like religious-religious.
I grew up in a Catholic household
where everyone believed in God,
and they were practicing,
but I just didn't know where I stood in that.
I would go to church,
but I wouldn't take in the messages.
I wouldn't really understand what was the meaning.
But now I've been like trying to get more aware,
and I've been trying to connect myself,
which sometimes is really hard,
because something bad happens to you,
and you're like, why me?
Why did you put this obstacle in my path?
But then you realize
that it's just to make you a better person.
It's to somewhat test you,
because God tests his people.
He tests people for the better.
I don't know what else to say.
Thank you for sharing.
Chloe?
So this year,
it's more like stretching into the 24-25 school year.
This has been my first year of high school,
which is automatically already terrifying,
but this was less of like the ideal,
like not ideal,
but like stereotypical high school experience,
and more of just like having to figure out
how to manage 12-15 hour days,
and higher expectations,
and how grades actually count,
and just new forms of anxiety
that I never thought I would have to feel.
And like this was the first year,
like as a three,
most things come easily to me,
and I vividly remember sitting down,
and my mom was like,
you know,
Chloe,
this might be the first year
that you're actually going to have to try
and work for things,
you know,
harder than you used to.
And I was like,
yep,
figured that out pretty quick.
And so I feel a lot like
my faith has grown a lot stronger through this,
and it feels like I've only like
needed more of God in my life
outside of church,
and tried to like not just be here
for this hour-long service,
but to also bring him home,
and like talk to him.
And me and my family have this little term
for Sunday nights
before going into a school week,
which is Sunday Scaries,
and so I'll just be like
lying in bed on Sunday night,
and I'm just like freaking out,
and I'm like,
I'll just start praying,
God,
I'm pretty scared, man.
I don't know what to do.
There's a lot of tests this week.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
If I fail,
I don't know what's going to happen.
Will the grades tank?
Like, will this one week affect
what colleges I get into?
And then I'll just be like,
no, it's okay.
And so,
as well as praying more,
I find that sometimes when I pray,
I put it off until like
the very last second at night,
and then I'll be like,
dear God,
and then just fall asleep,
and it doesn't happen.
And so what I found is
I start like,
I've always journaled,
but it's kind of like
meaningless journaling,
and so this year,
I've started like journaling
like with a set purpose,
and I start everything with like,
dear Jesus,
and it's like I'm writing
a letter to him almost,
saying what I'm worrying about,
and then just kind of
sending that off
and releasing my worries
along with it,
which has been really helpful,
so I'm excited to keep
growing my relationship
and becoming a better version
of myself.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
Well, thank you.
As we wrap up tonight,
this is kind of a question
for all the audience.
I encourage you to reflect
on your own journey.
Where do you need
accountability?
How can you be more aware
of your own strengths
and weaknesses?
How can you better support
and encourage those around you?
Let's be gentle with another,
but also firm in our commitment
to growth.
It's been really nice
to share with all of y'all
how life's been like for us,
what's on our minds.
So I think I might end off
with a quick little
impromptu prayer.
All right.
Dear Lord,
thank you for this evening.
Thank you that we
have the opportunity
to share how we're,
what's on our minds,
how we're feeling
with the church.
Thank you that we could hear
from these wonderful people,
all the cool hip ideas
we got going,
and please guide us
with your strength in mind
and your grace
and unconditional love
guiding us in every decision
we make in the future.
Amen.
All right.
Thank you for,
thank you for listening
to us yap up here.
Thank you.
So what we do,
I think most of y'all
know the drill,
but what we do here
is we practice
what's called an open table.
So even if your
faith alignments
aren't quite in tune yet
or you feel on the rocks
about certain things,
we, within faith
and everything,
we still invite you
to come up and partake
with communion this evening.
So this is the Celtic call.
This is the,
this is the table,
not of the church,
but of the Lord.
It's made ready
for those who love him
and those who want
to love him more.
So come.
You who have much faith
and you who have little,
you who have been here often
and you who have not,
you have been here often
and you have not
been here very long.
You who have tried to follow
and you who have failed,
come, because it is
the Lord himself
who asks you,
has his will
that those who want to meet him
should meet him here.
Thank you.
Wow.
Before I send you off tonight with this blessing,
if you lost some jewelry in the ladies' room,
please see Risa tonight at the tech booth.
She'll get you taken care of.
Okay.
Open your hearts.
Open your hands.
Take a stance to accept this into your hearts
and know that it's true.
Oh, Harper, are you doing a closing tonight?
Come on up.
Let me send you into your week with this blessing.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day,
and this is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead
with this yet-to-be-determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
go, filled with the assurance that you are loved,
you are worthy,
and you are accepted just as you are.
And go, filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same gifts
for grace and unconditional love
to everyone you come in contact with.
♪♪
Above and below me,
before and behind me,
in every eye that sees me,
Christ be all around me.
Above and below me,
before and behind me,
in every eye that sees me,
Christ be all around me.
Oh, oh, oh,
♪♪
Whoo!